so for instance roger penrose uses this
as an argument to say that there are
certain things that mathematicians can
do
dealing with infinities
and by extension our mind can do
that computers cannot do yeah he he
talks about that there's the human mind
can do certain mathematical things
that the computer as defined by the
universal touring machine cannot yes
what so that it has to do with infinity
yes it's one of the things so he is
basically pointing at the fact that
there are things that are possible
in
the mathematical mind and in pure
mathematics that are not possible in uh
machines that can be constructed in the
physical universe
and because he's an honest guy he thinks
this means that uh present physics
cannot explain operations that happen in
our mind do you think he's right and uh
so let's let's leave his discussion of
consciousness aside for the moment do
you think he's right about just
what he's basically referring to as
intelligence
so
are is the human mind fundamentally more
capable as a thinking machine than a
universal turing machine no
but so he's suggesting that right
so our mind is actually less than a
turing machine there can be no touring
machine because it's defined uh as
having an infinite tape
and we always only have a finite tape
hormones perform finitely many
operations yes
it can do the kind of computation the
yes the touring machine cannot that's
because he thinks that our minds can do
operations that have infinite resolution
in some sense
and
i don't think that's the case our minds
are just able to discover these limit
operators over too many parts to count
what about his idea that consciousness
is more
uh more than a computation so it's more
than something that uh a touring machine
can can do
so again
saying that there's something special
about our mind they cannot be replicated
in the machine
the issue is that i don't even know how
to construct a language to
express this statement correctly
well
the the the basic statement is
there's a there's a human experience
that includes intelligence that includes
self-awareness that includes the hard
problem of consciousness
and the question is can that be fully
simulated
in the computer
in the mathematical model of the
computer as we understand it today
roger penrose says no
so the the
uh
universal turing machine cannot simulate
the universe
so the interesting question is uh and
you have to ask them this is why not
what is this specific thing that cannot
be modeled and
when i looked at his writings and i
haven't read all of it but uh when i
read for instance um the
section that he writes in the
introduction to and wrote to infinity
the thing that he specifically refers to
is
the way in which human minds deal with
infinities
and
that itself can i think easily be
deconstructed
a lot of people feel that our experience
cannot be explained in a mechanical way
and therefore it needs to be different
and i concur our experience is not
mechanical our experience is simulated
it exists only in a simulation the only
assimilation can be conscious physical
systems cannot be conscious because
they're only mechanical cells cannot be
conscious neurons cannot be conscious
brains cannot be conscious people cannot
be conscious as far as you if you
understand them as physical systems
what can be conscious is
the story of a system in the world where
you write all these things into the
story
you have experiences for the same reason
that a character novel has experiences
because it's written into the story
and now the system is acting on that
story and it's not a story that is
written in a natural language it's
written in a perceptual language in this
multimedia language of the game engine
and in there you write in what kind of
experiments you have and what this means
for the behavior of the system for your
behavior tendencies for your focus for
your attention for your experience of
valence and so on and this is being used
to inform the behavior of the system in
the next step and then the
story updates with the reactions of the
system and the changes in the world and
so on and you live inside of that model
you don't live inside of the physical
reality
and
i mean just just to linger on it like
you see okay yeah it's in the perceptual
language the multimodal perceptual
language
that's the experience that's what
consciousness is within that
within that model within that story
but do you do you have agency
when you play a video game you can turn
left and you can turn right
in that story
so in that dream world how much control
do you is there such a thing as you in
that story
like
is it right to say the main character
you know everybody's npcs and then
there's the main character
and you're controlling the main
character
or is that an illusion is there a main
character that you're controlling i'm
getting to the point of like
the the free will point
imagine that you are building a robot
that plays soccer yeah and you've been
to mit computer science you basically
know how to do that
right and so uh you would say the robot
is an agent that solves the control
problem
how to get the ball into the gold and it
needs to perceive the world and the
world is disturbing him in trying to do
this right so he has to control many
variables to make that happen and to
project itself and the ball into the
future and understand its position on
the field relative to the ball and so on
in the
position of its limbs or in the space
around it and so on so it needs to have
an adequate model that abstracting
reality in a useful way
and
you could say that this
robot does have agency over what it's
doing in some sense
and the model is
going to be a control model and inside
of that control model you can
possibly get to a point where this thing
is sufficiently abstract to discover its
own agency our current robots don't do
that they don't have a unified model of
the universe but
there's not a reason why we shouldn't be
getting there at some point in the not
too distant future and once that happens
you will notice that the
robot tells a story about a robot
playing soccer so the robot will
experience itself playing soccer in a
simulation of the world that it uses to
construct a model of the locations of it
lacks on and limbs in space on the field
with relationship to the ball and it's
not going to be at the level of the
molecules
it will be an abstraction that is
exactly at the level that is most
suitable for past planning of the
movements of the robot
right it's going to be a high level
abstraction but a very useful one that
is as predictive as we can make it and
in that side of that story there is a
model of the agency of that system so
this model can accurately
uh predict that the contents of the
model are going to be driving the
behavior of the robot in the immediate
future but there's the hard problem of
consciousness
which i would also
there's a subjective experience of free
will as well
that i'm not sure where the robot gets
that where that little leap is because
for me right now everything i imagine
with that robot as it gets more and more
sophisticated
the agency comes from the programmer of
the robot still
of what was programmed in you could
probably do an end-to-end learning
system you maybe need to give it a few
prayers so you nudge the architecture in
the right direction that it converges
more quickly but ultimately uh
discovering the suitable hyper
parameters of the architecture is also
only a search process right and as the
search process was evolution that has
informed our brain architecture so we
can converge in a single lifetime on
useful interaction with the world and
the problem is if we define hyper
parameters broadly so it's not just this
the uh the parameters that control this
end to end learning system but the
entirety of the design of the robot like
the
there's
you have to remove the human completely
from the picture and then in order to
build the robot you have to
create an entire universe because you
have to go you can't just shortcut
evolution you have to go from the very
beginning
in order for it to have because i feel
like there's always a human
pulling the strings
and that
makes it seem like the robot is cheating
it's getting a shortcut to consciousness
when you are looking at the current
boston dynamics robots it doesn't look
as if there is somebody pulling the
strings it doesn't look like cheating
anymore
you